hi everyone it's joanna here i'm sure
some of you have followed a lot of home
workout videos or perhaps some of you
have just started your fitness routine
in the gym some of the fundamental
movements when it comes to exercising
includes your squats lunges push-ups and
also planks do you
know if you're doing the exercises
correctly
and why is it so important first of all
is to avoid any unwanted injuries if you
were to continue doing the wrong
form eventually it could lead to back
pain
knee pain and any unwanted injuries
secondly
in order to see results you have to make
sure that
you execute the exercises correctly in
order to hit
and target the right muscle group and
thirdly
you need to have a solid and firm
foundation
by having a firm and solid foundation
you can progress
further in your workouts okay so today's
video is about
learning the basics of doing a proper
squat
lunge push-up as well as a plank
so we will be learning what not to do
and
how to execute each exercise correctly
so let's start with squats
squats is one of the best exercises to
work
on your lower body the big muscle group
your quads your hamstrings as well as
your glutes okay
so squats pretty much we use it in
almost every single workout
some of the most common mistakes we tend
to see
is that people tend to push their knees
forward when doing a squat okay so then
they try to push their knees forward
and when they push up they're using
their toes
if you find yourself doing this and you
feel in balance
this is wrong okay this
is not a squat eventually you're gonna
start
feeling the ache and pains on your knees
so how do we do a proper squat all right
first of all
i want you to grab a chair or a stool
before we even get started i want you to
make sure that you're standing in a
neutral position
something i always mentioned in my video
stand shoulder width apart so it should
not be
too narrow or too wide shoulder width
apart
find the center find your balance and
make sure that your chest is
upright and you're looking straight
ahead okay and the reason why i want you
to have a chair or a low stool because
this is going to be your guide okay so
when doing a proper squat what i want
you to do is aim to push your
butt back first and sit on
the chair or stool okay and remember to
keep your chest
up throughout so stand shoulder width
apart
toes pointer forward look straight ahead
push your butt back
and sit down on the chair all right so
push your butt back
sit down on the chair and come back up
and as you come up remember that you're
pushing
using your heels not your toes okay
let's try that again push your butt back
sit
and push up through your heels so you
can't be sitting on the chair this way
correct you can't see it this way so
remember
knees should not go over your toes let's
try it one more time push your butt
back sit on the chair if you want to
face front sit on the chair and now get
up
and push through your heels push up
and engage your core tighten your core
that's
a proper squat so eventually
once you're doing it without the chair
it should look
just like this down up
squeeze your glutes down
up okay 90 degrees knees
do not go over your toes down
and up chest up
back flat squeeze and
keep practicing good up
and push good job so remember three
points
push your butt back keep your back flat
the power should be coming
from your heels okay and finally your
knees
should not go over your toes
the next movement is your lunges
typically i tend to hear people say that
they can't find their balance or they're
feeling the strain on their knees
okay so this is what you should not
be doing typically what they tend to do
is when they do a lunge
there's no focal point so their legs
just go back
and they just lose balance okay do not
do that
and secondly they tend to lean their
body forward so
another common mistake this is not a
lunge all right
this is going to hurt your knees and
eventually hurt
your back remember this is wrong as well
all right so how do we do a lunge
correctly
first of all what i want to do is grab a
high stool or even
your kitchen island something high which
you can support
your body against all right so i'm going
to use
my bar stool
so if you can't find your balance i want
you to hold on to something
to give you that extra support and
balance so before you even do a lunge i
want you to make sure that you're
standing in a neutral position
so just like your squat stand shoulder
width apart with your toes pointed
forward okay
find your center point all right now
support
your arms just on the stool and as you
take a step back i'm going to step back
with my left
foot remember that as you take a step
back your left foot is still
shoulder width apart so it should not go
across
or even behind your right foot that's
when you're gonna feel that you're out
of balance okay
so remember step directly behind
both my feet are still shoulder width
apart okay
take a white step and as you come down i
want you to imagine that
both your legs should be in a 90 degree
position
and come back up okay so remember
body upright chest upright lunge down
come back up it's not this
okay brace your core suck your belly in
down and up again
the power should be coming from the
heels of
your front leg i should be pushing up
through my front
heels not my toes all right if you're
leaning forward that's when you're gonna
be
pushing from your toes again
let's change leg left leg forward right
leg back remember step
shoulder width apart back all right if
you can't balance yourself
grab hold if not release it place your
palms in front of you lunge down 90
degrees
up down and
up there you go down and
up and try to drive your knees as low as
you can
and come up so do not rest so you should
feel the work
on your front thighs glutes
and also hamstrings and up and
back reset so that's how to do a proper
lunge you can always start
by holding onto something for extra
support
alright
the next workout is push-ups okay i know
push-ups
it's not easy it's not an easy workout
it's a tough workout it really works on
your
chest your shoulders as well as your arm
strength okay ladies especially for
ladies
push-up is not easy and it can get
really frustrating
if you can't even do one push-up
don't worry today i'm going to help you
to get your first push-up in alright
so let's start by explaining what you
should not
be doing the wrong way to do a push-up
all right so
get down onto the floor typically the
mistakes that people tend to do is that
they tend to either dip their hips
so they tend to do this remember this
is not a push-up because you're not
engaging your core muscles at
all or they tend to pike their butt
up this way this
is also wrong okay because you're not
again engaging your core muscles and
you're not
maximizing the work on your upper body
all right
the right way to do a push-up is to get
your upper body in a straight line it
should be
moving up and down as one unit okay
so down up
and down can you see that my body is
moving as one unit
and if i were to lower my body down your
palms
should be next to your chest slightly
wider than shoulder width apart okay
and if you want a firmer grip what you
can do is spread your fingers apart
push your body up as one unit come back
down
and up okay so
lower yourself as low as you can
keep your arms in a 90 degree position
and push
yourself all right
some of you might not even have the
strength to do
a knee push-up so what you can do is
grab a higher platform okay
either a stepper a bench or even
just using your kitchen island something
high
basically the higher the platform is the
less weight you'll need to push
all right so again same thing spread
your palms apart slightly wider than
shoulder width apart
make sure it's firm okay and take a step
back you don't have to go too far
this is wrong as well just take a step
back making sure that your chest is in
line with
the bench and slowly lower yourself down
try to get your chest as close to the
bench as possible
and push yourself back up all right
down and up and as you can see
my body is not changing it's in a
straight
line i'm not packing my butt i'm not
doing this
or i'm not dipping my hips
it's about core engagement as well
straight line down and up you should
feel the work on your upper body
as well as your core okay so
that can be the start to your push-up
find a high platform eventually get down
onto the floor
and do a knee push-up and eventually
once you're comfortable with that
then you can progress and do a full
push-up all right
let me just quickly show you how to do a
full push-up
so remember the principle of a push-up
is
the same start if you want to start down
okay
if you're not sure about your position
just start down make sure that your
palms
are next to your chest slightly wider
than shoulder width apart
okay tuck your toes under and push
yourself
up in a straight line okay remember to
gaze
onto the floor do not arch your neck and
look straight ahead
okay gaze onto the floor keep in neutral
position lower yourself down in one
straight line
as low as you can push yourself up brace
your core
use the strength from your upper body
push yourself up okay
it's one straight line down and
up again down
and up good job all right
so push-up is not easy you have to
slowly progress
start on a bench eventually get onto
your knees
and then try your first full
push-up the final and probably
the most important core workout is plank
okay i'm sure you have done a plank
before and you might have even
challenged yourself to do
30 seconds of plank or even one minute
or even some
up to five minutes okay whatever your
challenge is
i want you to make sure that you are
doing the plank correctly in order to
engage your deep
core muscles and not strain your lower
back all right
some of the most common um mistakes i
tend to hear is that people feel the
pain on their lower back or the pain
on their arms rather than feeling it in
their core so here's what
not to do all right okay let's start on
our forearm
again common mistakes what they tend to
do is
they tend to dip their hips can you see
that my hips
are dropping if your hips are dropping
you're not engaging your core muscles as
well
at all this is not a plank okay this is
just going to strain your lower back
so this is wrong another common mistake
is that
once they're tired they tend to pike
their butt
up this is not a plank if you're holding
a plank for one minute and this is what
you're doing
then this is not a plank and i'm sorry
you're not holding your plank for one
minute this is wrong okay so
no dipping no packing your butt up all
right
another common mistake is that their
arms are too far forward
hence they're struggling to hold the
plank and therefore they tend to
start shifting their body weight all
over the place
this is wrong as well okay
right so let's start with
the basic all right so let's start with
doing planks on your knees
if you feel that you don't have any core
strength or if you're new to doing plank
my suggestion is to start on your knees
okay
right so get down onto the floor what
i'm going to do
is place your forearm onto the mat
make sure that your forearm [ __ ] your
shoulders
and your elbows are in line okay they
should be
in a 90 degree position all right so
it's not too far forward
or too far back 90 degree position
okay and what i want to do is just place
your pumps onto the floor
all right this is going to be more
challenging and what i'm going to do is
slowly
lift your body off the floor
again just like a push-up it should be
in a straight line
so i want you to brace your core
strength tighten your core
making sure that your body is in one
straight line no dipping
no piking okay so hold it just right
here
and just start by holding it for 30
seconds
and really engage your core and suck
your
belly in okay so hold it and
gaze down onto the floor do not look
forward okay this is going to strain
your neck
and it's going to cause your back to not
be flat as well
so gaze gently onto the floor
and just hold the plank right here okay
you should
feel the burn on your core muscles and
you should feel
the shiver on your abs as well all right
and eventually
once you're comfortable with this
position what you can do is get
onto your toes all right so get onto
your toes
to begin with you can spread your feet
slightly
wider this will make the plank easier
okay
so brace your core again one straight
line look
down onto the floor my abs are shaking
that is absolutely fine that's because
i'm engaging my core okay
eventually what you can do is step both
feet
closer in and hold the plank
this is going to be more challenging
whatever you do
do not pike do not dip
that breaks the momentum of working on
your core strength
so remember keep it flat squeeze your
glutes if you need to
keep your legs straight do not drop it
keep your leg straight
and just hold it and slowly
lower yourself down don't just collapse
all right
okay so that is how you should
do a proper plank remember three points
first is to make sure that your
shoulders and elbows are in the straight
line
and that your arms is in a 90 degree
position okay so not too far forward
not too far back 90 degrees throughout
the second point is to always remember
do not pike your hips
or dip your hips your body should always
be
in a straight line that's when you will
really engage your core
and also your glutes as well as your
upper body straight
line all right and the third point to
remember is that if you want to start
off
easier you can spread your feet wider
and if you want to challenge yourself
then keep them closer together
alright guys don't be greedy start off
by doing a 15 seconds plank eventually
increase it to 30 seconds and
one minute what is more important is
that you execute
this movement correctly in order to
strengthen your core
and to avoid any lower back pains these
are the main
four fundamental movements which you
will be using a lot
in your workouts so practice them on a
daily basis
and make sure that you're engaging the
right muscles and that your form
is on point okay if you're unsure of
how to do other workouts then let me
know in the comments below
and do also check out my home workout
videos healthy recipes as well as
fitness tips on my youtube channel and i
will see you
in my next video all the best